well hi how are you my name is Kol is
here hello I'm humanik Rosen we've come
from Chile to this lovely town of eyes
now but uh gonna say look we're on the
trail of Johann Sebastian Bach my
favorite composer dido come with a spine
enough llegamos here we are in transit
alluette I've dreamt of visiting this
house all my life when you I thought me
here even now we're here this is the
studio where body composed the furniture
dates from his time just look at it I
booked a meter
I mocean an emotional even though I'm
not as much of an aficionado as Claudio
I find it very interesting indeed a
fantasy more the way I'm gonna take a
picture of you now oh yeah yes
absolute I mean I'm absolutely
overwhelmed by the emotions i'm
experiencing right now I feel really
fortunate to be allowed to be here in
this house for me it's a dream come true
kuya lugar para me hace un verdadero
socho realidad
really look at the church what's its
name Bailey says this is st. George's
Church it played an important role in
box story he was baptized Syria da ba
porque él fue a volte sol aquí
solo asleep inside I'm very moved when I
think about johann Sebastian Bach's body
being held over the baptismal font it's
a hugely emotional moment for me
significa una emocion muy grande para me
we are we now almost las afuera we're on
the outskirts of eyes now with a
beautiful view of the city look honey
castle no nem we have to visit it don't
you think of course let's go
hey hey Kathy this is my book castle
what a beautiful place beautiful
no poet Goethe a hundred percent of the
ceiling is decorated there isn't a
single guy exactly
a thumper Figgis mosaic is simply
perfect you think it was a painting
because there are so many details but if
you look closely it's all made up of
tiny pieces of different colors it's
impressive working at Rosso de que tal
de tanto calor a impressionable tahoe it
does you've had a marvelous day we've
explored eyes enough and box birthplace
but I Xena has much more to offer than
ba anyone there are lots of other places
to discover like this one like this one
rod pod Castle you can't go to the
goodbye for now but all of you should
come to eyes enough and get to know it
as well ideals